the private sector will have to take it
to the next level
and we identified it back in 2016 uh and
said this is the opportunity we can be
to some degree that spacex of weather uh
and thankfully today thanks to cloud
computing with hpc specifically you can
run models on the cloud
thanks to the fact that
the scientific community is more
familiar with modeling you can create
your own models
and thanks to space technologies you can
create sensors like what we're doing
we're doing basically all of it
and you can really push the envelope on
the science and that's that's what we're
doing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel and in media
partnership with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders and today
we're going to be talking about tomorrow
welcome shimon alkabetz the ceo of
tomorrow.io
shimon served in the israeli air force
for 11 years in several managerial and
commanding positions multiple near-death
weather related experiences during his
service stoked a fascination with the
weather that little things that affect
us all
he's also passionate about soccer and
can recall any statistic whether you ask
him to or not
ximen holds a ba in economics from ben
gurion university and an mba from
harvard business school
shimon alcabetz welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm good thank you for having me
thank you very very much for letting me
host you on the show i am so excited
about what you're working on with
tomorrow io
literally you know helping us understand
our world better how it's impacting
businesses and and talking about weather
altogether through deep technology i
think it's it's just a fascinating lens
and so i'd love to dive deep into how
how you
you know got into this domain and how
you've figured the integration of
technology with with our world but i'd
also love to hear a little bit about
yourself so tell me a little bit about
your own journey and following into
tomorrow io
great uh so obviously uh i grew up in
israel uh in amoshav
in the galil
family of farmers uh i went to the
israeli air force and spent about 11
years
i had the military career mostly the
commander and strategic planner
and
at some point when i decided
to pursue a different career it was very
clear to me that
the tech industry and specifically
startups it's well is what i'm excited
about
um i was trying to kind of like um
think about the biggest challenges i
encountered and there were many many of
them during during my service um i went
to harvard business school right after
uh i left the military
um and reunited with good friends ray
gopher taizlotnik
over there in boston
and um we all shared very unique uh
experience related
to weather
it was a very personal experience about
how weather was challenging us on a
daily basis during our military service
from a tactical level to operational
management level and even a strategic
level that we had an understanding
how it really impacts every aspect of
the operations
what we did over there in boston is we
spent many months uh learning the
industry learning the the landscape the
technology how it works why the
solutions that we had in place in a
relatively mild weather country such as
israel uh wasn't sufficient enough and
we learned about
you know the status quo and we were
amazed we learned that there is a
significant
technology
impact and business opportunity
and that's how we start we decided to to
start a company
at the beginning was very focused on a
specific technique
uh all along the way we knew that the
the big
mission is that we can create a huge
impact in times of climate change and
build a technology powerhouse that will
help the world drive more accurate
weather forecast and better decision
making and over the years we evolved our
technology stack and product
to where we are today so that's how i
got to
uh doing what i'm doing today
so talking a little bit more critically
about weather
why is why is it so important for us to
understand whether on a scale not just
for for farmers or on a military basis
but but why is it something that may be
relevant for things that are not so
trivial if you could give me some
examples
for sure first of all we need to
understand that uh climate change is
here
and the impact of climate change is that
weather events are going to be more
extreme
and more
frequent
it's already happening
i don't know if in the past you know
israel had so many disasters related to
floods like what happened in tel aviv a
year and a half ago what happened in the
south
uh with the class of students uh two and
a half years ago
these are things we didn't see in our
own country so now take this very small
example and look at the global scale a
couple of weeks ago we had
phenomenal and unbelievable uh
flood events in germany than in the uk
in china and india
and uh basically what we're saying is
that the majority of the businesses and
every country is going to have to deal
with the impact of climate change
and um
we're saying that you know we're not
trying to prevent climate change from
happening it's it's it's a different
scope of problem to solve but what we're
saying is that we're already in the era
of consequences right and every business
from restaurants here in boston that
cannot serve customers outdoor if it's a
rainy weekend
uh to insurance companies that have much
bigger payouts
uh to on demand companies that see
spikes in demand
because of the weather and people sit
more at home instead of going to do
deliveries to autonomous vehicles and
and drones
that need to reroute based on local
weather conditions it's impacting almost
everything um
and now that you understand that it's
impacting so many things you need to
understand that you have to put systems
in place
why because without systems in place you
cannot manage that challenge proactively
and the systems in place the way we call
it is
weather intelligence it's more accurate
in hyper local weather forecast but also
software automation insights to help you
make the decision in the right time and
if you can automate the decision process
and not not not have a manual process
um
so it's really endless in terms of the
customers we're targeting it's so many
verticals one of the challenges we have
as a company is that there are too many
domains from transportation aviation
shipping
rails to utilities and renewables to
insurance companies on demand sports and
outdoor
more than we can go after i would say
now obviously you know we've been
getting weather forecasts for dozens of
years you know uh whether it's a local
through the local news stations or
whether it's through obviously online
you know what's what's wrong with what's
been happening until now it because it's
it gives the impression of being very
local when in every city we have our own
local weather man or weather woman
yeah so uh i don't know how many people
are aware of the fact that to generate a
weather forecast
you need to observe weather with weather
stations radars and such then you need a
model
where into which you assimilate the
observations and then you need the
powerful computing
to basically process the model the
output of the model is a weather
forecast
all of that value chain
is done traditionally by governmental
agencies namely noaa
in the us ism wf in europe the met
office in the uk these are you know noaa
is
not far away from the size of nasa this
is a significant investment in
infrastructure
how many technology domains do you know
that are still led end-to-end by
governmental agencies
even in in space nasa has started to
outsource a lot of its work to spacex
and other companies
and that has to happen the innovation
is very much limited a lot was done
don't get me wrong the countries those
countries the europe and and
and the us have done a lot to promote
science
but
like in every domain we're seeing the
private sector will have to take it to
the next level
and
we identified it back in 2016
and said this is the opportunity we can
be to some degree that spacex of weather
and thankfully today thanks to cloud
computing with hpc specifically you can
run models on the cloud
thanks to the fact that uh the
scientific community is more familiar
with modeling you can create your own
models and thanks to space technologies
you can create sensors like what we're
doing we're doing basically all of it uh
and you can really push the envelope on
the science and that's that's what we're
doing
um
as a company and why wasn't it uh
good i would i wouldn't say it's not
good
it has done a long way since the
beginning but the problem is that
even a country like israel
doesn't have reliable radar to
understand what's happening in real time
the forecast we're using in israel is
actually the european global model
israel is not running its own model
that is local to israel now we have a
pretty mild weather but in the winter it
becomes more challenging so right most
of the world doesn't have reliable
real-time information and forecast and
that's a big challenge that we're going
after
now did you know you know while you were
doing hbs and you were going around you
know your own career did you know that
you're going to end up dealing tackling
the weather
weather forecasting issues or is this
something that you came across as part
of an ideation process with your
co-founders
so um i was very familiar with the
problem and it's something that you know
throughout my military service you know
was very challenging
i will lie if i say that during my
service i said i'm going to solve that
problem i had no idea how to solve this
problem but when we met in boston and we
shared stories about it and started
doing the research and identifying some
technologies we can start as a hook with
i was amazed that
in this situation the government still
created technology and the industry
is basically repackaging the
governmental forecast nobody really
pushed the envelope yes there are big
brands
we all use them in the apps and in our
phones and such
but they never really created a unique
technology of of unique sensors and
unique models they just repackage the
outputs of the governmental forecast and
when i saw that
and when i uh together with my my
friends when we learned
about the impact of climate change and
what it's going to do the collision of
the two
was
something has to be done something has
to be done so we can have more accurate
weather forecast in the world we can
bridge that gap of lack of coverage in
many many countries
and and we can create a software
solution to manage those challenges and
we're doing both
so what are some non-trivial questions
that you're observing your customers
asking
you know more tangibly
things that they perhaps weren't able to
ask before to the traditional weather
forecasting mechanisms what what
questions are they now now able to ask
using your new technology
so um the most basic uh change in
innovation that that we did is that
if until today uh our customers had to
uh have no solution just use apps or or
the watch the weather channel
or in the best case use a meteorology
support via the phone
or stationing a meteorologist on the
customer location and asking hey well
what will be the weather
today
our customers let's look at the example
of the nfl
they get
business insights they get a calendar
view that tells them hey in this stadium
and that game that's what you need to do
the game will be pushed you should
cancel this game
the fans will experience the following
right or whatnot a city will get hey
flood events is going to happen in this
place you should open the sewage and
that's what you should do so we're
translating road data
to insights via software and we automate
that so you can even use data feed and
api to your own systems you don't need
even a man in the loop
if if you want to go that far some
customers do that
um and it's uh
it's it's a significant change so
for them it's like okay until today i
used to consume raw weather data or talk
to someone
now
everybody in my organization is
empowered to make decisions and they see
what's going to be the impact
right now walk me through you know from
a founder's perspective you know you're
building this technology and now you're
looking for some use cases of of
companies that may be interested of in
leveraging this data what is the
reception like right right from the
beginning when before you're well known
before before you've proven yourself
time and time again
what is the process that you have to go
through look like
look at the beginning
people were very skeptic
first let's think about investors
yeah there's no way we could start this
company
in ecosystem that is not the us
in israel we would never even get a seed
round
for for for the type of mission and idea
and we tried
uh
we just we wouldn't have any chance you
know now we raised 200 million dollars
because
i think there's more appetite to solving
big real life problems
in the u.s and specifically in the
silicon valley
with customers some of them were skeptic
i remember our first customer jetblue
we were meeting them and they said
listen let's do a pilot but we don't
believe you can actually help us but go
start in boston logan
if you solve this problem and you help
us be more efficient and safer
in this airport
it it goes a long way for us
and you know today we're serving all of
the jetblue airports in the world
uh we're doing the same thing with delta
incredible
um and at the beginning people were
skeptic can you really push the envelope
on whether no but everybody's saying the
same thing everybody is wrong
but
when you when you teach people to use
insights and to automate it and not to
rely on apps and non-professional data
and understand that if they put systems
in place
and they trust a partner like us to give
them data they can rely on an insight
they can act on
then
even if you don't change accuracy by a
lot
you create a significant business roi so
the challenge for us is to focus the
customer
on the business decision process on on
the roi they generate and not on is it
more accurate or less accurate
because this is just an input to the
decision you need to make eventually
100 now what what is really the the leap
or the differentiator here that you've
brought with you to tomorrow io that
that is really the differentiator that
pretty much no other agency in the world
was able to accomplish
with the dozens of years ahead of you
so then don't get me wrong everything
we're doing as a stand-alone can be done
like it's not let's i'm not interesting
myself and saying hey we did something
nobody else can it's a matter of
choosing a strategy and going after it
and the strategy we took was to build a
vertically
integrated business model and the
vertical integrated business model is
comprised of three or four elements one
is sensing
observing the weather in a way that
wasn't done until today
and in that context we are launching our
own satellites we're going to cover the
world with active radars to sense
weather
why the government didn't do it
because low orbit and small satellites
technology wasn't available and the
government cycle of planning is very
slow
in the next decade the government will
still launch major satellites each of
them cost three billion dollars our
entire constellation that covers every
point on earth will cost about 100
million dollars so that's one thing
the second thing is modeling
the government is not supposed to solve
business problem specifically the u.s
agency noaa is incentivized to solve the
taxpayer problems and save save people's
lives so they run
a local model in high resolution and a
global model
with relatively low resolution
the fact that we run our own models on
on the cloud enables us to fine-tune the
resolution and choose
whatever a parameter to focus on so if
we work with aeromexico for example in
mexico and they tell us they have a lot
of diversions because fog in the air in
the airport we say okay we will find you
in the model to solve the fog problem
for you
so we can
customize and configure the modeling
capability
and then the the third and fourth
elements are the software instead of
using the people support and and and
you know apps and and things like that
we're saying listen we built microsoft
excel for weather
a template for every job every vertical
you can have your own tabs you can build
your own dashboard that will tell you
what to do instead of looking at the
weather data
and it will provide you the business
insights now when you look at this
end-to-end approach
more accurate sensing with global
coverage
models that solve the problem
with hyper local capability
and software solution that provides
business insights this is very powerful
and i think it's very hard to replicate
that entire approach it takes a lot of
time a lot of knowledge a great team and
and a lot of money to be honest
and and it sounds like at the end you're
you're it's all about also shifting the
strategy and and helping helping create
a new narrative for what questions
should be asked and what questions are
relevant for for the different business
cases and helping them not just
you know leverage the existing the
existing information that we have for
existing questions about leveraging
similar information
in a different way to consume it in a
different strategy and i think that
that's that that's really an interesting
approach that you've taken and i really
appreciate you coming and sharing your
time and sharing it with me but but
shimon and i would really love to take a
step back and go back to your your
childhood a little bit and and hear a
little bit about what really fascinated
you
growing up what really sparked your
curiosity you know before the army
before hbs before tomorrow io
so i remember growing up and being very
passionate about
starting my own business since i
remember myself and i remember i have
also big passion for graphic design i'm
a terrible graphic designer but you know
i was using photoshop since i was
11 and it's very uncommon for uh someone
who grew up in a moshav in a village uh
and i just remember myself you know
creating logos and imagining business
stuff and and
then you know i embarked on my military
career and completely forgot it but
eventually as a child it was something i
was always passionate about building
something that creates value for people
and gladly amazing uh i'm very proud of
the mission of the company and that's
what keeps me up uh and motivated i love
it and what what inspires you today so
it would tangly within this mission what
really is your source of inspiration as
you you know wake up every day work so
hard continue to to lead this company
forward
um
honestly uh
three things
one is the employees
i really want every employee that joins
our company and is part of the the
mission to have a good experience and a
good outcome
i'm not talking about financial outcome
but really progressing the career and i
work really hard mostly because of the
employees um
the second thing is the customers and
the impact of what the company is doing
it would have been very hard for me to
work in a company that is doing what i
call p2p privilege to privilege solution
solutions
uh i think what we're doing about
improving climate security for the world
helping countries have better weather
forecasts helping
federal agencies like the us air force
make better decisions helping uh you
know delta fly safer this is important
this is about helping farmers in india
uh these are the things we're doing and
that
that is very much motivating and the
last thing i'll say is the investors um
you know they believed in the mission
they begged us when climate change
wasn't a big thing and whether
technology seemed like you know
something for crazy
uh folks to think of and and i wanted to
be a good outcome for them as well
perfect wonderful and what are three
words that you would that you would use
to describe yourself
um
it's very hard but i think uh execution
very detailed around around that
um
i would say also uh um mission because
that's really what's what's driving me
and my my motivation
and three sports i'm a huge sports
sports geek and and if you wanna
become my friend just talk to me about
soccer and we'll find a way
unless you're in the wrong side then
exactly then it's a quick way to become
an enemy shimon thank you very very much
this is wonderful best of luck with
tomorrow thank you for all the great
work that you're doing i just love this
integration of technology and our planet
in the world
and helping businesses make better
decisions and stay safe and stay healthy
[Music]
you